this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
more on them later in the video
hey 42 here have you ever done something
really really bad then immediately felt
a horrible sinking feeling in the pit of
your stomach when the consequences hit
home you know the kind of thing like
smashing a window with a football when
you were a kid or accidentally sending a
text to the person it's about rather
than the person it's actually meant for
i'm convinced it's one of the most awful
emotions you can experience as a human
being
the closest a non-jedi can come to the
feeling yoda probably gets when there's
a disturbance in the force
most of us react to these kinds of
situations in one of two ways we either
take a big deep breath
don whatever emotional armor is
available to us and then go and face the
consequences like the adults we are
or we do everything in our power to make
it seem like that bad thing never
actually happened in the first place
now i'd like to take a moment to talk
about hair loss because i've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their 20s and it's an upsetting
experience if you're in the same boat
then you're not alone did you know two
out of three guys will experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 but the best thing you
can do to prevent hair loss is take the
initiative now and do something about it
whilst you've still got hair left i like
keeps because it makes treatment super
easy by delivering your hair loss
medication every three months directly
to your door so you can say goodbye to
awkward doctor visits and waiting in
pharmacy checkout lines there's a reason
that keeps has more five-star review
than any of its competitors and hundreds
of thousands of men trust them for their
hair loss prevention medication if
you're like me you're probably not ready
to lose your hair just yet but
prevention is key the faster you act the
faster you'll see results and the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com
42
or click the link in the description
below to receive 50 off your first order
one man who firmly opted for the latter
approach when something terrible
happened in his life
was anatoly bogorski a particle
physicist working at the institute for
high energy physics in the town of
protvino about 60 miles south of moscow
but borgoski hadn't done anything so
trivial as smash a window or send a text
to the wrong person
no
his little mistake was so drastic that
to this day he remains the only human
being in all of history
to have ever actually done it
maybe it's best if i just start at the
beginning
as i said bogorski was a particle
physicist and his research at the
institute for high energy physics
was centered around something called the
u70 synchrotron
when i first heard that word i assumed
bugorski was into some random sub-genre
of techno that i'd never heard of but it
turns out the u70 synchrotron was
actually one of the world's most
powerful particle accelerators
a machine capable of accelerating
trillions of protons to within a
fraction of the speed of light
on the 13th of july 1978
bugorski was running an experiment using
this formidable machine as part of his
phd
but his progress was being hampered by a
series of repeating errors these kinds
of annoyances aren't at all uncommon
when you're working at the cutting edge
of science and bagorsky knew roughly
what he needed to do to fix the problem
but to do so he was going to have to
inspect some equipment in arguably the
most dangerous part of the accelerator
complex
where the main beam briefly passed
through open air
as you can probably imagine access to
this part of the facility was tightly
restricted
but as a researcher at the institute
bugorski was one of the few people
allowed inside and so he rang the
control room and requested that the
particle accelerator be shut down
when he arrived on site slightly ahead
of schedule just under five minutes
later
he noticed that the red warning light
always switched on when the accelerator
was in use
had been switched off
he also found that the access door he
needed to use which was kept locked
whenever the accelerator was running was
unlocked
with no reason to suspect anything was a
mess bugorski opened the door and
stepped inside
he then crossed the room to where the
equipment he needed was located and
knelt down all the while trying to
figure out what was actually causing his
experimental errors
and that's when it hit him
not the root cause of his technical
issues
but a concentrated beam of trillions of
ultra relativistic protons
to this day nobody seems to know for
sure why the particle accelerator hadn't
been powered down as per bogorsky's
request
in all likelihood it was a simple
misunderstanding
but whatever the reason
it shouldn't have mattered as i've said
there were safety measures in place
designed to prevent anyone from
accessing this particular part of the
facility when the colossal machine was
running according to some reports the
light bulb that was supposed to indicate
when the accelerator was on had burned
out at the worst possible time
but others claimed that safety protocols
had simply been ignored or forgotten
about considering the incredible
energies at play in a particle
accelerator it's strange to think that
the beams themselves are completely
invisible to the naked eye
when bogorsky approaches equipment that
day he had no way of knowing that
streams of protons each carrying 7.6
billion electron volts of kinetic energy
were whizzing through the air all around
him
well not until one of them passed
directly through his brain
the beam entered through the back of his
head rocketing through his middle ear
and the occipital and temporal lobes of
his brain before blasting out his left
nostril
apparently there was no pain but
bagorsky did report seeing a flash of
light that was and i quote brighter than
a thousand suns
he knew instantly what had happened and
considering who he was and where he
worked
it's safe to assume bugorski probably
also knew that in the blink of an eye
he'd just become a dead man walking
after all he just received a local dose
of radiation of between two hundred
thousand and three hundred thousand rent
cans
for reference a dose of around 400 rent
guns that's 500 times less radiation
than bogorski received
is almost always fatal if left untreated
one hundred thousand rent guns about
half the radiation he received
typically kills within an hour even with
the best medical care on the planet
but here's where bogorski's oh [ __ ] i
made a mistake instincts kicked in
because rather than you know go and tell
someone that he'd just been blasted
through the brain by one of the world's
most powerful particle accelerators
he calmly finished checking over his
equipment
wrote up a report in the lab's logbook
then went back to his desk and just
generally carried on with his day
as if nothing had happened perhaps
unsurprisingly he wasn't able to keep
this little secret for long
during the night his face swelled up
like a kind of fleshy water balloon and
the skin around his invisible entry and
exit wounds began to peel away
as though he'd been shot in the head
with the world's largest death ray
which he basically had
no doubt resigning himself to the fact
that these strange injuries were going
to be fairly difficult to explain
without admitting the truth the next day
bogorski spills the radioactive beans
a few hours later he found himself
surrounded by experts in a specialist
radiation clinic in moscow
after running some calculations to
figure out exactly how much radiation
their new patient had been exposed to
the doctors quickly reached the
inevitable conclusion
bugorski was going to die
fast
as the first person in history to have
suffered this kind of unusual injury
bugorski briefly became the subject of
much scientific interest
with soviet medical professionals hoping
to gain valuable data on exactly how
long it takes for a person to die
horribly after being no scope
headshotted by a particle accelerator
[Music]
but
as the days went by these highly
observant doctors began to notice
something a little odd
namely that their terminal patient
wasn't actually dead yet
even more remarkably he seemed to be
getting better so much better in fact
that i'm happy to tell you anatoly
bogorski the first and only man to take
a particle accelerator beam to the face
is still alive and well today almost 45
years after the incident that changed
his life not that he came through the
experience entirely unscathed mind you
he lost his sense of hearing in his left
ear the nerves on the left side of his
face were all but burnt away and he's
had to learn to live with now
semi-regular seizures that have plagued
his life since the accident now i know
what you're thinking side effects are
all very well and good but which or some
superpower did he get
well i'm sorry to report that the answer
to that question appears to be a
disappointing
not
well not unless you count the fact that
he's able to defy time itself
because the nerves on the left side of
bogorsky's face were destroyed
only half of his face responds when he
makes a facial expression
since the repeated creasing of the skin
that takes place when we humans do the
old-fashioned version of emoting is an
important factor in the formation of
wrinkles the left side of bogorsky's
face has remained eerily wrinkle-free
despite his advancing years i mean it
isn't exactly invisibility or x-ray
vision
but it's better than nothing
okay time for the million dollar
question
if anatoly bogorski was hit in the brain
with 500 times the typically fatal dose
of radiation
why didn't he die
as is often the case there's both a
short and a long answer to that question
the short answer predictably enough is
that we don't know for sure
as of today anatoly bugorski is the sole
lonely member of a data set
of one
nobody before or since has ever been hit
in the head with the beam from a
particle accelerator and so drawing
definitive conclusions is tricky
this lack of data is compounded by the
fact that the accident happened in the
soviet union during the cold war
the soviets were notoriously secretive
about all things scientific back then
particularly in the field of nuclear
physics
and the entire incident was kept a state
secret for well over a decade as for the
lung answer well
it all comes down to the exact kind of
injury bugorski received
the way radiation affects the human body
might seem a little esoteric
but the reality is it's actually fairly
simple radiation damages your body in
basically the same way as bullets from a
machine gun
only on a quantum scale what i'm trying
to say is bogorski's head was basically
hit with trillions of tiny proton
bullets traveling at close to the speed
of light
these bullets were so unfathomably small
that most simply pass straight through
him without even bumping into anything
atoms are overwhelmingly made up of
empty space
and since you're made of atoms
so are you in fact as utterly ridiculous
as it may sound
you watching this video are made up of
99.99999999
empty space
kind of
in truth it isn't actually quite that
simple
but that's a topic for another video
anyway the tiny proton bullets that did
bump into things in bugorsky's brain
wreaked absolute havoc damaging his
cells down to the level of his dna and
causing mast cell die off hence all the
long-term side effects he suffered but
the key here is that the radiation was
focused into an incredibly high energy
beam that was less than the width of a
pencil
that had two effects first a significant
majority of the beam's energy went
straight through bogorsky's head without
being absorbed and second the
devastation caused by the beam was
confined to a relatively small area
the human brain is a truly remarkable
organ
if you've been following the channel for
a while you'll already be familiar with
a chap by the name of phineas gage who
in 1858 had an accident in which a
meter-long iron rod was blasted through
his brain in a construction incident
like anatoly bugorski phineas gage also
suffered from a range of neurological
side effects caused by the gaping hole
in his head
but also like bugorski against all
expectations
he lived to tell the tale
our brains have a remarkable capacity to
recover from even really quite serious
damage part of that comes when new brain
cells grow to replace old ones but even
more importantly the brain is able to
essentially rewire itself thanks to
something called neuroplasticity
allowing healthy regions to somehow pick
up the slack from damaged ones
all of which meant that despite his
catastrophic injury bogorski's mental
capacity was so little affected by the
accident
he was able to complete his phd in
particle physics
before going on to have a long and
successful career in academia there's a
rumor going around that size matters
and it certainly seems that girth was an
important factor in the case of anatoly
bugorski had the proton beam that got
all up in his grill being large enough
to engulf his entire body
there's no question he would have been
killed perhaps even instantly
well either that or he'd have become a
super villain and taken over the world
it's difficult to know for sure
but ultimately thanks to the strange
circumstances of this most unusual of
injuries bagorski was able not only to
survive but ultimately to lead a long
and relatively healthy life
i reckon he'd have taken that if you'd
have offered it to him on the night of
the 13th of july 1978.
[Music]
thanks for watching